have your hot breath water that's great
hot breath that's cool that you have
that nobody's branded like that that's
great
yeah branding you know yeah you bet so
uh had you heard of the show before no I
had not okay so when I saw it I was like
oh cool this is great yeah is it's all
comedy mastery um so I know we have a
lot of like parallels I didn't know if
it it enter your sphere yet well yeah it
doesn't it hasn't yet but it's good that
it's good to see it because you know
it's I think synergy is so much more
effective than comedian yeah you know
what I'm sayin so Queens are always so
insecure they're like I'm not telling
anybody anything these are my secrets
yeah you know so you still got to do the
work yes I mean you know I've
interviewed almost 200 comics and some
have been more hesitant than others
about like I don't even wait a sauce I'm
like I mean they lit they still have to
cook it like right right and you can
give them the recipe but it's gonna turn
out different because it's a different
chef absolutely so it's I've never
really gotten that aspect though I don't
wanna give away too much and most people
have been cool or I've coerce them into
revealing it once they're like oh yeah
they still have to live on stage for 20
years right exactly so let me give you
your proper introduction here all right
hot breath averse welcome back to the
hot breath podcast this is your weekly
guide to comedy mastery I am your host
comedian Joel Byers and our guest today
hot brethren and sistren
this is the man with the plan when it
comes to comedy all right this guy was a
25 year comedy veteran who was written
from everyone from Jay Leno to Chris
Rock to Bill Hicks up until he got
custody of his oldest son he was on the
road grinding a comedy 40-plus weeks a
year he has now since become in my
opinion the authority on comedy
education and really creating platforms
and resources for comedians to learn the
tools they need to become successful
comedians so he is the perfect guest to
have on
he just recently started his own podcast
right they end up comedy clinic it's not
launched yet okay we're just like you
had recommended at the seminar your
backlog like 10 14 episodes before you
put it up okay perfect so definitely
this is one you're gonna want to listen
to multiple times and share with other
comedians a lot of people out there are
attempting to teach this craft but from
my research he has the best platform I
mean if you go on as YouTube he has more
hits than anyone else if you go on his
website he has more resources so if
you're looking to learn about comedy
this podcast is the tool for you and now
our guest you now know is the tool for
you so without further ado welcome it's
a hot breath Jerry Corley everyone Jerry
quarry thanks well I'm glad you did that
research because I didn't know that I
had more hits so oh yeah oh your YouTube
page is killing it it's a lot of fun I
mean it just started I started one time
putting out one video and the video was
47 minutes long okay and it was
basically it was called how to write
there uh how to write fifteen jokes in
30 minutes and it was based on a
headline
Tiger Woods falls out of the world's top
20 and so and then I just basically
showed the process of writing the jokes
and so it took 40 no editing was just
there and I didn't know much about
YouTube just put it up and now it's God
I don't know it's got like three hundred
thousand or over three hundred thousand
views how long ago was that that was
seven years ago seven years ago was your
first video no first video I put up yeah
now if you if you even just search
comedy like you're like the first hit
that comes up that's cool anything about
how to write a joke right how to stand
on stage how to become a comedian the
year the good good to know yeah is is
there a rivalry within because there's
some top I mean there's some like
players and then in names we know like
Greg Dean and Judy Carter is there is
there a rivalry between I think there I
for me no I don't feel a rivalry I don't
think anybody's my competition and not
to say I'm above anybody else I think
it's I think you learn you don't become
a doctor from just going to one
sir mm you know and so I have books that
line my bookshelves almost any book that
was written about comedy yeah I have it
on my bookshelf it's not like I focused
on one dude and said he's the only one
you know that would be ridiculous
but it's like even Melbourne hell it's
Erzberg comedy writing secrets is which
the sort of the just the absolute
foundation of what I started that was
based on gene parrots comedy writing
step by step okay so but it was more
written as a sort of a journalist's
point of view a more lay person's point
of view if you get gene parrots book he
kind of drills down and almost makes it
tedious where you start getting you know
sometimes there's too much work you know
whereas Melvin in comedy writing secrets
made it really kind of easy to get into
it and so I found some sort of balance
that worked more as a comedian right so
what I saw that Melvin helots er was
doing as a journalism professor teaching
comedy writing at Ohio University and
what gene parrot was doing as Bob Hope's
head writer I was like malama comedian
I'm taking this stuff taking it on the
road trying in front of audiences then I
would have some theories go out tried in
front of an audience then write down all
my notes okay so I sort of had worked
used the road as my lab you know and it
was just that's how and then I realized
it was helping other students how good
that felt to see them go up there make a
change to a joke and it got a real crisp
laugh and you go yeah I was like that's
a good feeling
so then Booker's started putting new
guys on the road with me to help them
get better and so I said this is a lot
of fun and then when I was given that
the custody by my oldest son and I was
like in the road work just stopped like
you know that pattern disrupt you here
in a commercial you hear that
Denton incident and it ended and and
they build the pace and you have to get
up and get the kids ready for school you
got to get another breakfast get them
and make sure their dress make sure they
have enough mittens and then diarrhea
that sort of record scratch sort of
thing uh-huh
well we hear that all the time in
Camaros we hear that pattern disruption
used all the time and so that was my
career it was like things were moving
forward my manager was calling saying
hey we're booking a bigger bigger
where you know next thing you know we're
gonna start doing arenas things are
really going well I've got these things
lined up for you and then the judge says
you have your son or pull custody yeah
it was like diarrhea yeah but he was not
doing well in school and he said to me I
want to live with you mom stresses me
out mm-hmm and so I talked to the mom
mom was like you know I he said I said
Keith wants to live with me she's like
over my dead body I said it doesn't need
to be that exciting and so she she
resisted and I said well we'll go to
court then and the judge made a pretty
much instant decision just spoke to my
son and then said we're done here and
you even said you like cancelled like 20
weeks of work did ya we're just like we
didn't work I had to cancel yeah oh my
god I remember those phone calls and as
I finished got through the whole list of
people I was booked with I was like okay
now what and I was I had a writer's form
at the Friars Club in Beverly Hills it
was just me and first and so you know
like 30 guys would get together on
Monday nights we'd eat dinner and then
have some drinks and hang out and I said
you know we got the cigar room over
there that nobody uses what are we going
there write some jokes and I got these
weird looks and one guy said I've had
the same act for 25 years you know it's
like why you know why would you do that
it's so much fun to write a new joke so
it started we started the writer forum
it was just me and three comics and then
over a period by six months it was me
and 27 of the comics they were in the
room and they kept looking to me I was
just doing it sort of a group
collaboration thing but they were saying
you fix jokes you know how to fix the
jokes you seem to know what's missing
how do you do that
you're the joke doctor you know and they
started every time I'd walk in they go
hey the joke doctors here and that kind
of how is how I got the name the joke
doctor you know oh cool and you don't
think the jokes will fixing fixing the
jokes is how you create tags for like
Bill Hicks and Chris Rotten right you're
exactly Comedy Store just watching them
and they're like hey have you thought of
this right that way and also when I was
doing my writing in the mornings doing
my current events writing
you know one of the best lessons I got
was from Jean parrot never edit yourself
in the first draft so one of the jokes
would be deemed racist if I did it but
if Chris Rock did it
it wouldn't be and the joke would
contained the n-word so I'll say the I'm
gonna say it without saying the n-word
because we know what happens when you
say things right Shane Gillis right so
we don't want to you know and if anybody
really listened to the context of what
he said in that podcast he wasn't saying
it himself he said the people said let's
put them there oh yeah but it was like
forget it your words had once first
Asian superhero now on Marvel C mulu
who's gonna be the first Asian superhero
I think it's awesome the guy's awesome
as an actor an athlete he's got a great
sense of humor
but he the way he heard it he tweeted
about it and tweeted at SNL and at NBC
of course you've got Marvel this big
film launching this movement of
Millennials who love Marvel and then
they're like well we have a choice I
think the optics don't look good here
because we're also hiring the first
Asian yep not-ready-for-prime-time
player which made me say really in 45
years who's the racist SNL right yeah
yeah Jim Jefferies brought up a good
point of he brought up a character I
think I may have been Mike Myers that
played it back in the day but it was
just him like being exaggerating race
racial I came here what race he was
playing but he he pointed out like three
examples of SNL characters who were
blatantly racist but in this time and
I'm sure you've seen and how long you've
been doing comedy like you probably
won't even pitch this Chris Rock joke
anymore just to him because I would I
would pitch it right to him but it would
private like I did before I pulled the
most yeah so the joke was this is how
old the joke is this is mayor this is
when you had the those two Ethiopian
guys who were taken into custody and by
the NYPD and one was sexually abused
with a plunger I don't know you don't
remember this but it was a big story in
the 90s and
so NYPD had this racism issue and I said
basically Mayor Rudy Giuliani issued a
memo to the NYPD telling them they need
to be more polite so now when they pull
you over they say step out of the car
mr. n-word okay right and I I know I
could never do that joke I hate that
word I grew up in a you know in just
this tremendous tremendously wonderful
family musical theater parents we had
everybody over and it was like that was
like a famous character right it was
character actor and it's like so I
didn't really know there was an issue
with different colors of skin till I was
much older so it was like 10 or 11 but
it's a kid growing up everybody was over
at the house so so when I when I wrote
that joke I said I could never do that
joke but Chris Rock could do it because
he's working on a piece right now
dealing with this very subject and I was
down at the Comedy Store and I pumped
into him he didn't even know me I said
hey man you don't know me but I wrote a
joke today that would fit in perfectly
with the segment you're doing on the
NYPD he goes lay it on me and I told him
and I said it's not my voice so hey you
know yeah I laid it on amigos now I see
why it's not your voice did you say the
word yeah to him I said the said it goes
and he did the joke in the main room it
got an applause break and he says and he
said you write more like that I'll I'll
pay you for them I go [ __ ] that you're
paying me for that one I saw the
response and he took out 50 bucks and
gave it to me Wow yeah and it was like
that's how that's how it started just
sort of just write stuff but I'd listen
to Bill what Bill Hicks who approached
me one time when I did a segment in my
act and he asked me if he could have it
he said because it would fit perfectly
in a piece I'm doing and I said but I
you know respect what you're doing I
don't want to step on your toes and I go
well that's of course that's not even
the funny part you know I was a kid and
he did it and got a big applause break
on HBO and I was like oh crap
yeah it was like gorgeous yeah right
yeah exactly it's like there
you will be oppressed through whatever
it's like he did his whole religion ran
and he's like well then forgive me it's
like a famous it's exactly what my when
we were traveling cross-country my dad
you know my was met his mother for the
first time and I was a little 12 year
old Punk and she said Jerri you're gonna
have hell to pay and I say what's he'll
cost these days grandma hey give me 379
and an eternal flame and she smacked me
mm-hmm and then my dad actually took her
by the wrist and said you will never
strike my kids mother and she goes how
am I going to get you know except this
Pat if you can't accept Jesus into your
heart he says will you forgive me you've
never understood this you forgive me and
I did that as a piece and then that's
when Bill Hicks approached me and I was
like you know I didn't even know who he
was at the time you know it was that
long yeah I wasn't even he was just like
a working cop he was coming up he was
just coming up is his first HBO cousin
really did that piece what was that like
being at like The Comedy Store and being
around like though these are like the 1%
comedians you know yeah this um it was I
was just starting so I didn't really I
wasn't commiserating or hanging out with
any of the guys but it was just these
random I would bump into people and just
randomly meet them and next thing you
know I just started to sort of hand off
jokes you know you became like you were
almost like the the joke plug you could
write jokes for people and you were
starting to make money that way right
and making a little money and I would
and then when I'd see open my kurz I
would just give them jokes you know and
I'd listen to their bits and and and
just write tags and Stoppers and my
little notebook tear it off and say hey
man that piece you do about the Hummer
right maybe these would be good tags and
they go wow that's really funny ago you
could have it if you want it to go I can
just have it sure you know jokes are a
dime a dozen but even the the Jay Leno
job came about you you got him on the
phone somehow and you know just pitch
him a joke in the moment yeah here I
talk about it in depth because I did
once and it got out there and I got a
call because when I was fired I signed
an NDA and so there's a lot of specifics
I can't talk about
there was politics involved and so I'm
not you know it's like with with my
movie that I wrote was like there are
certain things I'm not allowed to say
because you sign these things of course
a you know anything could be looked at
as you disparaging somebody in Tuesday's
so you know it's so weird I mean part of
me goes I can talk about yeah I got
fired because I they were working on
pushing me out because it was well I
can't really talk about it because it
was a it was sort of uh it was a
personality thing in that somebody felt
threatened because I was writing a lot
of jokes because the guys who trained me
gene parrot and Bob Mills Robert Mills
was gene parrots contemporary and Robert
Mills was an attorney in San Francisco
and he basically responded to a in a
writing lesson joke writing lesson from
jean parrot thing correspondence course
and then he said hey you're not sending
me in more courses he said you're the
first person that has gotten gone
through all of them so he he brought him
down to LA and got him a job writing at
Dean Martin roasts and then he got a job
writing for Bob Hope and he's the one
that said he said I would write for Dean
Martin from nine to five and then I'd
write go home have dinner with my wife
and write 100 Bob Hope jokes from 7:00
to 10:00 and that opened up my brain go
wait a second you can do that you can
write a hundred jokes in a day were in
three hours so I wound up hiring them as
mentors and you know coaches and they
would just weekly push me and push me
and push me and so when I started my
website that's when some of these older
writers contacted me by email and said
please keep doing what you're doing cuz
the kids coming in these days have no
structure yes so that was that was why I
was like oh okay so I'm on the right
path yeah and you're speaking of mentors
you also had like George Carlin became a
mentor yeah what is rising this was like
you know you go back and look at the
stuff and it's like I go back and said
wow the universe was just sending me all
these gifts until I went back and just
thought about all these things I go holy
cow
remember uh this lady who is uh she's
kind of one of those spiritual psychic
ladies and she said do you realize all
the gifts that were being passed to you
by the universe I go what do you mean by
that you know and she sort of mapped
them out for me I go holy [ __ ] she's
right
so I what happened I was doing my first
corporate in New York City at four
Chemical Bank and my dad's agent
actually booked it he heard somebody
wanted something he said hey you want to
do this gig I said yes three thousand
dollars so I said I'll go do it two
years in a comedy right exactly right
and you know cuz he knew I had an hour
clean material and I go do this thing
for this Bank and so I go out to New
York and I get up the next morning and
I'm heading I you know I get up after
the gig and I'm going I go down to the
little pad there where the cars come in
to take me to the airport and I'm
sitting there and you know waiting for
my car and it's not showing up and
there's no cell phones I couldn't just
pick up the phone and call I couldn't
call an uber and this guy goes hey you
going to the airport and I turn around
go on okay looks a lot of Courland man
and so he says I said yeah he says you
want to ride with me JFK I said if it's
not an imposition he said sure you look
like a nice guy I get in the car and
he's as hi my name is George and I'm
like gulp you know my name is Jerry
Jerry Corley he goes you any relation to
the character actor Pat Corley I said
well that's my father and he goes well
my agent said I should study him to
become a better character actor and I
said who's your agent he told me his age
and I got this my dad's agent so we just
started talking yeah and then he said
what do you do I said I paint houses
I couldn't tell Carlin I was a comedian
oh you're getting amazing it what came
out in the conversations yeah eventually
because we're talking and I go
I memorized your albums man and I
started doing like tracks from his
albums I'm like wonderful I know in
western Walla Walla I was doing the
stuff he's like how old were you I said
eight years old because you listened to
my albums when you were 8 years old he
goes yes and what about the language I
said my dad said there was my dad and
mom both agreed that there's no bad word
there's just inappropriate places to use
certain words because they're literature
people and you know musical theater
people and Broadway people so in that
literature there's you know profanity so
if you looked at it as bad words then
you would address him differently and we
didn't use them much when we were kids I
would just use them when I was reciting
Carlin albums and I said and they said
if you have any questions about the
language ask us and so I asked a lot of
questions as a kid and how did their
relationship grow with George and what
was he like he said any time he says
look any time because when we got
towards the I see the sign that said
departures and I said this this is gonna
end really soon and so I said you know
what would be your best piece of advice
I may never see you again
he goes I hope not you know but he meant
I hope so right I hope you won't
I hope not you won't see me again well
whatever right so he said I said what
would be your best piece of advice he
said there's a line cross it mm-hmm
that sounds like a metaphor George give
me something that's more concretely mean
I don't want like is that do you mean
touchdown or line crossing or what does
he mean exactly he said he said you ever
read the newspaper watch the news and
call [ __ ] and I said all the time he
said make that your comedy but make it
funny here's a trick raised the bridge
and that was that means raise your
eyebrows when you're delivering
something that you're angry about and
it'll change it from you being angry and
judging maybe this audiences ideals to
this is absurd I don't understand it I'm
confused
interesting Jon Stewart uses it all the
time or did it use it all the time in
yeah on The Daily Show we'd go this is
crazy
why are they doing this I find I have a
habit of doing this so it's just raise
your eyebrows instead and perceive
difference yeah watch Bill Maher
struggles with doing that he tries to
he's like it gets in a weird twitch so
did you get did you see George again
yeah the next like two months later I
was in Vegas and he was playing at the
celebrity room at at Bally's and I
called the hotel there and I said George
Carlin
carlins room please and they put me
through I left a voicemail figuring he's
busy who I won't hear back I go out I
come back to my room at 5:00 p.m. and
there's a message it's George Carlin he
says hey great to hear from you why
don't you know come by see the show I've
left some ticketed will call and then
come back to have afterwards and police
combined say hello so I have this I grew
up in the theater that's what theater
people say right and so I got the ticket
and I afterwards and went back to the
stage manager and said George said to
come by and say hello he's and he said
are you Jerry I said yep
and so I went back there and we wound up
talking for about two hours and I kept
saying am i keeping him here you know I
don't want to impose and he said we just
talked he gave me a you know glass of
wine we just sat and chatted and it was
just a great time and then we talked
about we started talking about comedy
and you know some places I would you
know question and have a counter
proposal and he was like great
he says um and he said and that's when
he said to me I know with 98 percent
odds that a joke is funny before I step
onstage and I said how do you know that
yes said because it contains all the
elements necessary for a joke to be
funny I said what are those elements he
said you're gonna have to learn those on
your own kid really and then later on
after another glass of wine and a pain
pill because that was George's drug of
choice at the time he said I think the
reason I said that was because
instinctively I know what they are but I
can't Birbal eyes them mm-hmm
maybe you can do it and then come up
with some ways so you can explain to
explain it to the world and I said I
took that as an order so of course if he
says Oy that's what I start that's when
I really got into studying why do we
laugh yeah and you're almost like a
historian like you take it like you take
back your references to like Socrates
and yeah you go all the way back to like
the source code of laughter and you well
I wanted as a kid as a five-year-old kid
I always took apart my toys to figure
out how they worked okay so I figured
with comedy I wanted to do the same
thing
why am I doing this and when they at
least feel like I'm empowered to work on
the applied approach a joke with
confidence right rather than what do I
do
let me just pray and hope it's gonna be
funny so now I can write a joke and know
with high odds that it's gonna be funny
because and I'll even point out why well
because it's got this it's got
incongruity it's got surprised it's got
this is plausible and I can put those
pieces together and get up there with
high confidence and deliver joke yeah
cuz George Carlin actually had an office
that he reported to as anyone else with
a job would do and that that's I'm glad
you brought up older riders encouraging
you to take this approach of technique
and all these different elements of
comedy because a lot of especially now I
mean I don't know if this is a newer
thing or you've always noticed it but it
seems like a lot of comedians are trying
to just get by with like attitude and
just being like being like yeah this is
funny because I'm saying it cool but
really there's gotta be a punchline
exactly you know in fact we can go back
and talk briefly about that
so the Leno thing what happened was
something happened in Leno called me
because I sent a letter you know my dad
said my dad sent a letter and so I sent
a letter and then to the Tonight Show
yet to the tonight because you were
feeling well I felt their joke was
stolen
you know Oh verbatim it wasn't even it
was an evergreen joke and it wasn't even
it wasn't even a version of it it was
verbatim and I know who did it and I
know who was at the show that night and
then 24 hours later it's on The Tonight
Show verbatim and I don't okay that's
that's not cool so I I told my dad about
he goes write a letter I don't know am I
gonna write a letter dad don't be write
some letters it's stupid so so I wrote a
letter right and and two months later I
got a call from Jay and a hold though as
I'm answering the phone I heard this
voice I'm like what one of my friends
does a really great Jay of course and
then I realized it was him and I just
said to him I said Jay I've got you on
the phone my job is not to get off this
phone until I have a job writing for you
and then that's when you and he goes all
right well you gotta I can't do your act
I go well you did even Touche
and then he said you gotta be up at the
current events and then he said like
this morning Oahu Hawaii lost power to
the entire island what would you do on a
joke like this now I'm sitting there
going oh my god another gift because I
was watching the news that morning and I
see him now in his office watching CNN
and the chyron says exactly what it said
at 7:00 a.m. when I was writing Oh wah
hoo hoo I lost power to the I entire
island traffic lights were out court
buildings were shut down at about a
hundred thousand kids stayed home from
school today
and that's a threeway buildup all I have
to do is remove the third mm-hmm and now
I have to and now I have to disrupt the
pattern and but still a you know so it's
infrastructure infrastructure you know
court buildings traffic lights and then
show something else that's heightened in
reality but still reelect losing
electricity so I said and a vacationing
Don King was seen with flat hair so and
that's when Leno goes huh and I said
that right on the phone in that moment
because you just thought of that I go
yeah I just thought of it of course I
had been writing it earlier mm-hmm a lot
of comics back then said well that was
luck I said that was luck I said no well
luck is opportunity meets preparedness
and because I was writing every day
because gene parrot said treat yourself
like a professional now and that means
right every day and set it up in your
schedule right every single day and I
read that Jerry Seinfeld was writing
five hours a day so I said I'm gonna
write five hours a day and so um I need
to have the calendar with the red X's on
every day he writes and don't break the
chain make the change so I had that
calendar up there I was doing all of
that so yeah and that's what happened I
mean so then he was like okay you got
the job
that's on the fun we're gonna he started
me as a contributing writer so they sent
release forms that that day I signed
them sent them back and that night I
wrote a hundred Zachary Taylor jokes cuz
it was a big deal Zachary Taylor I think
what 17th 18th President United States
was being his body was being exhumed and
they were trying to determine whether or
not he was poisoned and so that was a
big deal and so I wrote
joke's on that and then faxed them over
now what I loved about it was the facts
they still had that thermal paper you
know that slow oh yeah and I sent a
hundred jokes on several pages so that
they thought the fax machine was broken
and they got my out of all the jokes I
submitted they used one that day and it
was the more mundane of all the jokes I
wrote I thought that's not even the good
that's like a transition joke why would
you use that but it taught me a lesson
on The Tonight Show they look for middle
of the road because you're trying to
respond to middle America not the coasts
got so the joke was something like
Zachary Taylor and 19th president United
States the body was being exhumed CNN
apologized for not give being able to
give us pictures of the crimped you know
because there's a centerfold you
wouldn't want to miss silly joke I love
you I love you do it his voice yeah I
used to every time I would do a joke I
delivered in his voice just a seasoned
vet damn it does it fit does it fit and
so I would do this you know did those
impressions of him and you did that for
like eight years he wrote for him yeah
after that yeah Wow so that that's crazy
it started out with I guess you were at
a stand-up show and then like the next
day you're like oh I did that joke at a
show and then now it's on The Tonight
Show let me write a letter now I have a
job at the tonight right exactly
so that's that's well you know it was it
wasn't even that my old I just wanted to
do stand-up and I but I wanted a really
write be a good writer and the best way
to do that is to practice the best way
to practice is current events jokes yeah
because current events jokes you see
them every you just take headlines and
lines in the news and then take some a
straight line and try to make it funny
rather a lot of people make the mistake
of going to the weird news trying to
find the weird news that's already funny
and well you have nothing to do you just
state what's weird right so instead just
taking a straight line and then making
it funny that's the difficult part so I
definitely want to roll our sleeves up
on the actual work of comedy as well
like I want it I want to make sure we
get a lot of just the context of your
career and just how qualified you are to
be the authority you are on
but your approach to the work of comedy
is inspiring and like you're talking
about I'll just write for five hours a
day because I'm feel said but I mean
I've gone through phases where I'm like
I'm riding every day and this is great
and then it's like you miss one day and
then one day turns into a week and then
a week turns into a month and then it's
a year mm-hmm you're like wait where'd
my writing habit go like literally what
kind of tips do you have for comedians
to start that daily ritual we all know
we should do and we all feel better when
we write but it there's seems to be a
block with us just staying consistent
you know well I think that's with
everybody and everything like if you're
like if you're alts Arnold
Schwarzenegger or the rock he's in the
gym every day that's what he does it's
like his religion it's non-negotiable
and when I decided I was gonna write it
was gonna be non-negotiable I had to get
every day I had to be in that seat and
it was like I know comedians who have a
day job who adhere more to the schedule
of that day job that they hate than they
do to their writing schedule because
they impose it upon themselves and I
think there's a couple of blocks there
one is a lot of comedians get into
equate comedy with frivolity and
therefore they treat their careers
frivolously and so it's like I kind of
got into this to beat the system you
know so why would I adhere to a system
if I don't want to be in a system and
comedy serious businessmen when you're
making 40th your minimum pay is four
thousand a week writing on a Late Show
then it's worth it's you better work
your butt off if you want that job it's
it's harder than you think
but you know so if I get up every day
and I my that my day is basically I make
my coffee I sit down with my laptop open
it up at the kitchen table and I'll say
okay I'm gonna look for 10
I'm gonna look for I'm gonna start with
three headline jokes mm-hm and then I'll
just take three headlines and with those
three headline jokes I'll usually write
say 15 jokes per headline and that that
gets me started
okay so then and that'll be then I'll be
like an hour and a half in or something
like that and I'll write some more and I
might get inspired to go off on a
different place sometimes I sit down I
go okay today
I'm gonna do I assign myself like on a
certain day so I'll assign myself
today's cliche reformations so I'm just
gonna grab ten random cliches that
everybody's familiar with and that can
include book titles movie titles slogans
for corporations I'll just write those
down and say okay I'm gonna write some
takeoffs and some reformations so a
Reformation is taking the first part of
the cliche and then coming up with a
second ending right so it's like WC
Fields if at first you don't succeed
our brains are running try try again and
all you all he says is quit there's no
use killing yourself over it so finding
a cliche and finding a second ending so
then I'll do a few of those and that'll
just or if I do one awesome I'm inspired
because there's some days you wake up
you don't you don't feel like it exactly
so if I do one or two of those I'll be
like wow I'm feeling like it now I feel
inspired because I came up one joke when
Joe can change your whole viewpoint of
how you feel about writing today you
just have to show up every day you just
force yourself and we're about a
five-hour habit but would you start off
like okay I'm just gonna sit down and
write one joke every day and then it
like grows into oh I wrote one now I
feel like writing five more you just
kind of yeah it's darting goals in fact
that's what Jeanne parrot said to me sit
down write one one joke a day next week
change it to three jokes a day next week
double it go to six jokes a day because
if you could write three you could write
six
it was tough when I started hitting 18
and 30 and I was like I'm tapped he goes
push yourself and I got past 30 to 60
and then then Olson it just grew and
every threshold I hit and passed it I
knew if I could pass that one I could
pass this one and so it sort of became
like trying to be an athlete towards
your writing you know I'm gonna push
myself further and if you're not sitting
down every day pushing yourself to get
better you're not improving we see
comics do this all the time they plateau
and they sort of stay the same with no
reinventing or no new discoveries as
comics they're just the same you know so
it's like how are they how do they
expect to get better if they're not
doing anything to improve are you
improving the amount of mics you're
doing
per week are you improving the amount of
jokes you're writing are you trying to
come up with fresh stuff are you
replacing the mundane jokes that get me
the ocher laughs with laughs that get
you no real punches and applause breaks
if you're not effectively doing that
you're not really doing anything to get
better it's pushing yourself past your
comfort zone so that's uh that's kind of
what I try to do
how would you overcome writer's block oh
there's lots of cool things to overcome
writer's block first of all there's like
cliche reformations those are fun right
wordplay just taking fifteen random
words and you can go to what website
that has a random word generator right
it's just Google random word generator
and I'd write 15 random words and come
up with alternate meanings for those
words just that process sometimes it's
not even thinking about being funny it's
just here's an alternate meeting and all
sudden an idea comes to you oh crap I
can use this for this you know say the
word peace you know well peace would you
like a piece well which like a piece of
what you know and also now there's a
potential for most comedians think think
cynically or sexually so piece could be
piece of ass so if my wife says cutting
some cake and she's Jerry would you like
a piece I said yeah then I'll take some
cake you know and now I were oh I didn't
realize that before and it becomes like
something called frequency illusion you
know when you buy a car and then
suddenly you see that car everywhere you
thought the car was unique everybody has
his car right but it's like now you
understand that you can take a meaning
of word and come with come up with
alternate plays on it because you now
know that's possible now it's started
and you start to practice it in your
regular interaction with your comedy
buddy your sister your brother your
mother your wife your husband you you
know now are training your brain to
recognize that opportunity yeah like I
like I guess as comedians we we're like
I got to write down and write my genius
bit today but it's almost like taking us
if you have writer's block take a step
back from your material just write
something silly just racially around
silly simple some of the best jokes are
the simplest Anthony Jeselnik
everybody loves most comedians let me
just say most comedians love Jeselnik oh
he's a genius look at the structure of
his material
very simple setup an assumption shatter
the assumption mm-hm and but he does it
with his character his persona his
through-line
that's he's dripping with this sarcasm
and mischievousness that it's almost
like he's pranking the world it's like
he's just this little shrewd sly guy
he's like I'm gonna play a trick watch
this
you know and it's that's what makes it
fun you know so you know one of my
favorite jokes it's like he says you
know there was a these kids were playing
hide-and-seek in my neighborhood and one
kid they found three hours later or
three days later in a refrigerator and
everybody's like this heaviness you feel
that heaviness and he's like yeah but
who else could say they died a winner
[Laughter]
it's such a positive note how could she
be on the side of that joke right unless
you're the parent I guess yeah and
that's that's a specific style you know
and one of my favorite comics it was
like Ronny Dangerfield Mitch Hedberg and
when I actually started I was one liner
I was like a one-liner comic which i
think is a great place for comics to
start just to understand the mechanism
of building an assumption and then
breaking it any and edwards was on here
and he he broke down a one-liner and
then how to expand that into like an
actual like five-minute bit from just
one line you've heard of this and used
oh you can have whatever you want
no one ever have the brands and the book
I got it was actually a Greg Dean's book
yeah so that rig was my first down
oh so you took the classes Greg Greg was
my first teacher yeah he was the one
that taught the setup an assumption
shatter the absurd assumption exactly
yeah I mean it was like that is Wow
and that opened up my eyes to a lot of
stuff and then and then as I I wound up
sort of being an assistant in his class
so I was I would record his classes and
sort of trade that for tuition when I
was in his classes for a while and then
that
and then it just I felt I learned as
much as I could and then he sued you and
then he threatened to sue oh okay he
threatened to sue you he threatened to
sue me he said he said he when I was
starting to put on my blog and put up my
YouTube videos he called me and he said
you know I'm gonna sue you I go for what
Gregg he says you're basically copying
my book I said you show me anywhere
where I plagiarized anything you have
put in your book I'll share it with my
attorney and then if she thinks it's
anywhere close to being plagiarism we'll
take it down and he stopped bothering me
but he was like he's well you know too
dissimilar his ideas converging that's
mine I go you know who initially came up
with that Aristotle you know and he's
like what you know and I said and then
James Beatty in 1476 it was a he was a
philosopher coined that as well as being
a definition of a joke and he's I said
have you done your research you know and
he's like so for you to say you own it
it's like you saying you own this is
like Ford saying they own the internal
combustion engine mmm
you know it's like it's like if
Microsoft owes IBM a bazillion dollars
because they're the ones that came up
with uh you know the initial computer
right so it's it's you can't
and then when what Microsoft came up
with icons clickable icons for to
execute programs Apple sued them and
said that's ours oh wow and the judge on
a judge determined you can't you can't
really patent a concept like that you
know it's you can't say hey because we
use little icons to show to say you know
to support letters that that say that's
that's a patent you can't patent it see
it's all cool now I guess well I try to
make it cool right I tried to you know
every time I do a seminar I always
mention him that he was my first teacher
right because I try to promote synergy
because again somebody can go to him and
maybe get just a different version of
something and go
oh that flips the switch cuz it's not
about me it's about somebody learning
this amazing craft right so if it
because they heard something from him
differently and all sudden it opened up
their world that's a win you know it
doesn't hurt me it makes them better so
if I was part of that journey that's a
positive right so anyway I do sort of
that thing so here's what happened they
gave a little Dean story Greg does a lot
of passive-aggressive let's call it
passive aggressive behavior and plus
he's got the reason why I stopped
studying with Greg was this we were in a
class and this student was having a hard
time he was trying to talk about his
father obviously clearly by the look on
this guy's face he was having a
difficult time talking about his father
and there was some rage there and he was
having a hard time and Greg what kept
going how do you feel about this how do
you feel about this how do you feel
about this and the guy can see was
getting visibly rayji you know and I'm
like this ok Greg's working beyond his
credentials right now so I tried to
diffuse it you know Greg had this list
of all these emotions right and I said
hey Chuck what one of these emotions or
two of these emotions fits the scenario
of the story you're talking about when
you're talking about your dad he goes
this one in this one I said why don't
you say those and then and then execute
them you know maybe I shouldn't use the
term execute when he's that close to
rage right so he's but he said he said
oh yeah and he said the words which got
a chuckle in class and then he you know
did sort of an act out and he got an
applause break in class and Greg shot me
daggers man and after the class he was
just raging at me now dare you usurp my
authority I was like what it's not about
you man it's about this guy right this
guy trying to have a breakthrough here
we got a breakthrough it's a win but he
wouldn't let it go and so I said no more
this guy's nuts
that was and so that was it I wasn't
gonna I didn't go to his classes anymore
and then so then
[Music]
what we were told we talked about what
Greg Greg was ready story oh the great
story then for a fluke we were at the
world series of comedy and I was
teaching a seminar and Greg was
scheduled to teach a seminar so I was
teaching on Tuesday and Greg was
teaching on Friday so I teach my seminar
then afterwards after a show Greg was
mingling trying to mingle and he's a
little awkward in his mingle but the
student comes up to me one of my
students comes up to me and evidently he
took a class of Greg Dean too and he
goes hey how are you he goes uh you know
so you know you know man I was your
teacher he goes at any and the guy just
literally says well I study with this
guy now
and Greg got all kind of weird right and
then Jim Barnes just had a great set
gets off stage and Greg Dean comes over
to help them you know give them some
tips and stuff I said well you can come
to my classes it goes well I study with
Jerry Corley and Greg got all upset so
Friday rolls around and all these people
now start after Greg Dean's cemetery
come up and start talking to me and I go
what's going on and they say this they
say Greg got up there first of all just
talked about himself for 15 minutes and
then basically said you guys know Jerry
Corley and it was like yep he goes I
taught him everything he knows
and then so that's what he said now I
thought it was funny right so that night
Saturday at the finals everybody's there
right all the judges and for the finals
and I get Joe asked me to close the the
segment so the judges can tabulate the
scores so I go up there to do ten
fifteen minutes and I open with are like
maybe my fifth joke in I say I have five
kids because normally I say I have five
kids because I'm only half Mormon and I
say well I have five kids because
evidently Greg Dean also taught me how
to [ __ ] and the place explodes in the
back of the room while the comics start
laughing and he just started clapping
and Greg goes Joe goes that wasn't
really nice
it was absolutely necessary necessary
absolutely did he say anything do you
have nothing nothing bro your lap but he
did reach out to me just recently he
sent me a he just sent me a note and he
said hey I got this on this website I
found that this guy was copying and
pasting segments of my book and I found
this from your book and he said you may
want to give him a call and I said well
thanks so much for that heads-up Greg
okay maybe you're finding your way to
being okay with the fact that nobody's
taking anything away from you you know
and it's like there's lots of teachers
in LA and I don't worry about any one of
them you know cuz my only focus is
putting out the best content I can for
people to learn and a lot of other
people learning about how much money can
I make
yes if you put your mind there just like
you mentioned in your podcast about my
focus is not about making money it's
about putting out the best content
figure out the best value for my
listeners and that's where things come
back to you it's a it's a long-term game
not a short-term gain yes and if that's
what you're in it for because I am I
mean I love what I do and I love helping
people and I'm gonna continue to do it
until it's until I can't do it anymore
because I enjoy it I enjoy watching
people transform I enjoy getting and
having somebody deliver a bottle of
maker's mark and say thank you for my
career that's an amazing feeling
you know so it just feels good you know
you almost feel like it's your you
helping them get that laughs it almost
feels like you got the laughs as well
and you see it right because I I dabbled
with teaching some and but it came down
to and this is this all happened like
this year where I was like oh I'm gonna
start my own comedy school and like
really like really start to help people
teach in comedy but then I had to take a
step back because I was like I've never
been afraid of work but it's like
working in the right direction
and I saw myself I was like okay if I'm
gonna do this this is gonna become like
my job you know he and I had to be like
well why did I start comedy and I didn't
start comedy to teach
comedy I started coming to be a great
comedian and as soon as I had that
realization and I still help people and
I loved I mean if people ask questions
I'm more than happy to answer them but
as soon as I close the door on building
a comedy school like three months later
I'm taping my first comedy special and
then next month I'm going on like my
first solo tour it's like as soon as I
close that that comedy teaching door now
my career opened up Wow yeah that's
great you know do you find that in in
your even just life experience that you
just have to assess first why am i doing
this and that can almost become like
your guiding light in a sense well I
found out for me what happened with me
was I think there might be sin there's
definitely some value in that focus
laser being focused on what you're doing
when your intent is I think what
happened with me was I had I had this
vision of what I wanted to do I wanted
to be at first of all as a comedian I
wanted to be a triple threat I wanted to
be able to sing dance and do comedy very
old school I studied tap I you know I
used to close my big like when I did my
hour-and-a-half show I would close with
singing the star-spangled banner as a
character named Fritz the freedom fairy
which is a character based on my best
friend from New York was a New York City
firefighter the camera to the closet
about 15 years ago and so I do this
whole thing it because he's he's
sprinkled throughout the act and the
whole act is really was just a story and
it wound up people used to come up and
say I love your message and so the
message seemed to be tolerance and
across races and across sexual
preferences and all that and it just
sort of because that's the way I was
raised you know I was raised my dad
raised us with a philosophy of wouldn't
it be great if we could take care of
everyone we can't but wouldn't it be
great so that's kind of the way we were
raised yeah and so that's kind of the
through line of the act it turns out and
but because of the the singing and all
but it was so at multiple so in my
pursuit for comedy I thought not only do
I want to do stand-up I also want to be
a really good writer so I couldn't
increase my revenue streams plus I was
acting you know so I was able that I was
doing commercial
and then as I was writing my comedy I
was dabbling in in screenwriting and
then and that's how you know in dabbling
in screenwriting I wound up writing the
movie stretch for with with joe carnahan
actually has a screenplay by credit
because that was the deal and getting
the film made which was interesting Wow
because but I still say I've got six
drafts of the [ __ ] so I when I
say I wrote it I wrote it and my boy
Rob Rose came down to LA and and wrote
it wrote versions of it with me -
because he's a defund it past this
funniest guy I've ever met and then when
we met Joe Joe loved it and basically
sat down with us said we're gonna get
this film made but here's the deal I
have to get screenplay by oh my gosh
we'll make your movie if you say it's by
yeah yeah basically why now I had an NDA
with that one too and I'm not supposed
to talk about it but the company I
signed the NDA with was dissolved to
form another corporate company so that
they could fight fight it paying us
residuals so I don't have the NDA now
with that one they don't exist so do you
have any other NDA's floating around
well anytime usually any time you do a
script with a company you have to sign
documents that say you won't disclose
won't disparage won't you know and I
don't talk that I'd you know Joe did
great things we made a movie and a lot
of other filmmakers I talked to said
first time you do something usually
gonna get [ __ ] and so when I was
talking to a good friend of mine Dave
Connolly I was complaining about getting
[ __ ] and then he sat me down with
another writer who wrote some pretty
substantial films and who has not hadn't
had a hit hadn't had a movie sold in a
while but we had lunch together he goes
I would love if I was getting [ __ ]
right now you know so I was like I guess
I want to get [ __ ] gonna have I in
fact when we sat down with our meeting
with Joe I brought a brown paper bag and
inside the paper bag was Lubin condoms
really and I just said be gentle
why that
that was it but we got a film made and
and so now that the film the film got
made other doors have opened you know
people see you as legit this one
producer from Marvel met me and because
his wife was in one of my showcases and
he says he basically said hey yeah I'm a
producer for Marvel I'm not looking for
any script so I said I don't need to
give you a script I got my own and he
goes tell me more and so I told him he
goes stretch it was I just watched that
what with Jessica last night I love that
you did that Wow we have to talk cool
and then he came into another one he's
like so uh do you have any do you have
any comedies you're writing because I do
things on the side I do under 10 mils
you know that means I do with production
budgets above an hundred and ten million
now yeah but producer asking you for
something so I was like sure all right
when I write something marvelous I'll
make sure I get it to you you know and
then I walk away I don't stay there and
Joe yeah you know I just walk away
you know I act like I'm my own entity
you know without I'm not begging for a
job sort of thing you know
yeah and it's important I think that
you're like I want to be more than just
one thing right and in researching you I
heard you say comedy or comedians should
think like entrepreneurs without a dump
please expand on that well we don't we
think like broke comics we think you're
cordis it's a mindset and when I learned
I tell you what I was when I was doing
my stand-up I was also teaching comedy
traffic school and which is a group I
recommend this for any comic who really
wants to have a captive audience first
of all you're working as an emcee you're
you have to get a state mantid mandated
curriculum out to the to this group of
people while making it humorous what a
great training ground for eight hours so
I was doing this and I know what was
going well because there's a when we'd
have like a Wednesday Thursday evening
class the second night I had a dude show
up with his wife he goes I brought my
wife I go why it's date night this is a
traffic school you know he goes yeah but
it was so much fun last night you're
cool with it right I go sure
and so it whatever what I was obviously
getting laughs and they were still
learning the material and so that for me
helped me to branch out to doing warm-up
for television shows it's perfect Anna
same thing basically and then what I did
was I was I had this guy in one of my
traffic schools who was president of the
Chamber of Commerce and he came up to me
and he said I'm the president of the
Chamber of Commerce he was there for
rolling a stop sign and he said we do an
annual dinner every chamber in the
United States does one of these where
they swear out the old officers and
swear in the new I would love you to
emcee it and do 30 minutes to stand up
I'll pay you $800 and give you beer and
I was in college at the time and I
thought broke you know and I thought
beer I'm in and so I did did the event
it went really well
I got a videotape up and I hired a
videographer right which was six hundred
bucks at the time investing in your
sound so was I made $200 total on the
gig and got that video and then two
weeks later at the neighboring cities
Chamber of Commerce called me and said
hey I heard you did a great job over at
Chico would you come and do ours how
much do you charge me I thought the
going rate would he ate was 800 I didn't
know I could negotiate so I took the gig
and I thought to myself how many
chambers of commerce are there in the
United States seventy six hundred and
fifty and I had to go down to the
library to get that data because we
didn't have the internet back then and
so I basically got a database for 200 of
them in the region of Northern
California sent out flyers via fax with
me at the dais at the Chico Chamber of
Commerce saying change your annual
dinner to an event
hire a professional comedian to emcee
and I got a bunch of phone calls that
came in I booked 28 in a three-month
period all at $800 and I said I've got a
career I've got a business and so that's
how I started going out and doing
corporates I love the catharsis of doing
the clubs but the clubs don't pay
like corporates do Oh No so then I was
able to up my dollar amount for other
corporate events and then I said what is
a Chamber of Commerce it's an
association
how many associations are there in the
United States too many to count but
according to one of the databases that
track associations there is like 2.3
million all wanting a comedian to do
their event they just don't know it yet
they don't know how it fits hmm
but with the Chamber of Commerce since I
knew they did annual dinners and most
mother's most of the time they can't
find the person that really wants to
emcee it that's their pain point and so
I offer a solution to the pain point
just like every commercial does right
you know pain point pain point pain
point solution that's how you sell
something right so just and when I was
becoming a comedian booking myself I got
a sales kit you know how to be how to be
a good salesman because I knew I'm gonna
have to sell myself that's I hate sales
but might as well learn the techniques
entrepreneur and that helped me to book
that helped me to book a lot of stuff
and that helped me to get it to get a
manager an agent because I was already
working mm-hmm you know I went in and
show him how much I'm working there so
yeah we want to sign you it's funny to
say Chamber of Commerce because I did a
Chamber of Commerce event last year and
you're making me think I need to email
every Chamber of Commerce in the region
now because I did that one they need to
know but if they know where it fits how
does it fit how is it a solution for us
because if you just say comedy they're
like okay what comedy where does it fit
but if you find a place where it could
fit like MC for their annual dinner that
fits what if and so I said hmm what can
I do and I read this thing in a Business
Journal that said the California company
is small businesses we're facing you
know twenty eight million dollars in
settlements legal a liability sell
settlements for sexual harassment
lawsuits and so I came up with a 20
minute routine on how to alleviate
sexual harassment or how to recognize it
and alleviate it you got to know what it
is first before you alleviate it and I
prepared it a humorous sort of thing a
comp be still a stand-up act with us
with a speech so in
Meishan laden with a lot of humor points
built in and then did a offered a free
luncheon to the Rotary Club and they had
me and I did a free I said the caveat is
don't tell anybody it's free and so I
delivered this 20 minute thing on
tolerance in the workplace and pitched
it from the angle of pain point twenty
eight million dollars in liabilities how
many of you small business owners are
prepared for this I can deliver this
thing on on alleviating sexual
harassment in the workplace by
developing tolerance and so I went up
and delivered this thing 25 minutes they
loved it 15 20 people gave me business
cards hey we gotta have we have a
Christmas party we have a golf
tournament we have this we have this and
I booked all these gigs so they came to
meet with that you know it sounds like
the entrence thinking like entrepreneurs
means think outside of just the comedy
club structure yeah
I mean starting your own show is a way
yep but also finding there's events
everywhere there's birthday parties
there's family reunions like think
outside of we get there's the old school
where like but you gotta rise the ranks
of the comedy club but it's like the
business of comedy is way beyond just
trying to emcee feature than headline a
comedy club so far beyond in fact and
and just a little note I don't say any
of this to brag because money to me is
just a result of you doing something
positive it really is and I think if you
keep it that way you never have the ups
and downs of success and failure you
have the joy of doing the work for the
sake of the work my dad taught me that
as an actor and I live by it so in this
case word got out that I was teaching
comedy there was this doctor and my one
of my lots of my classes he loved what I
did and he gave the word he gave the
word to the director of Kaiser director
of Kaiser for West LA called me and said
Jerry I'm thinking about I'm doing a
seminar where I'd like to teach doctors
to use humor in the workplace because I
want their clinic to visit visits to be
more like you know house calls
can you help doctors develop a sense of
humor in the war in the clinic visit I
said that's right down my alley
and so we had
look phone calls and he said how much I
said $5,000 he said no problem he said
I'm gonna run it by the board first he
said is that all and I went yeah no
problems so he said oh that's just for
me showing up right right I can't change
it then but what happened they passed on
me so three days later a week later I
got this call from this guy who's they
and he called me up he said you know
they went with some mucky muck from
Cisco or talks and from Oracle and all
these big companies so but his name is
Dan something rather so this guy calls
me up named Dan saying he needs help on
how to use humor
Kenny can I coach him on that because
he's got a speech for Kaiser he's
talking to 200 doctors in the morning
200 in the afternoon and they're paying
him $40,000 40 40 thousand so I said I
can help you with that he goes how much
will that cost me I go $5,000 because I
wanted to make back the money I lost so
we agreed and he was miserable as a
student he was arrogant he refused to
adapt things and learn the jury I don't
need to self deprecated I know I'm very
knowledgeable and I researched my stuff
and I'm good at what I do I said what
you're talking to doctors they need to
know that you don't feel you're superior
to them because they're doctors so if
you self-deprecation stal ittle bit
they'll trust you more he still refused
I said you know what I can't work with
you so just give me half and good luck
six months later I got a call from the
director of Kaiser he said that guy he
didn't do so well so he wasn't that he
didn't live up to our expectations do
you still are you still willing to come
help us out with this event
yes sure he's your fee still $5,000 I
said no sir
it's now 40,000 and he said I'm just
curious why is it more I said well
because you worked with a guy and he
didn't do it for you and you paid him
40,000 he goes how do you know he called
me up for coaching and he was miserable
to coach with he goes haha I I can I can
see that he said I have no problem with
the price
in fact the board might like it more
because that sounds more legit to them
and that opened my mind to how we think
about money and how other people think
about money
comedians think about money is like as
oh my god I've got a piece of gold I'm
gonna hold on to it forever right
because we don't there's not a lot of it
going around yeah but these guys think
of money in a whole different way drop
in $40,000 for an afternoon Wow
and then what they were trying to do is
get this to go national as a program for
Kaiser so they were in contact with the
Director of National Kaiser who's in
Hawaii and then what happens he now
retired so it's kind of a dead issue
have to reignite it and get it back
going again but if you can you know say
I had no idea I could ever get paid that
much for one event never you know and
when that happened I went that's a whole
new world they've probably passed on you
because it was so low that's right it's
not legit right exactly and it gave me a
whole different way of looking at it we
think if somebody afford if we quote too
much they're just gonna run away mm-hmm
and then no they usually counter because
they're not as emotional towards money
as we are yeah we're like Oh $50 in
chicken wings okay
experience in the mic type of course and
I did a lot of that stuff always I drove
for you know just to have the get the
mic time somewhere encounter a new book
or do something for free of course no
yeah I use my because because I had kids
I used the the sort of the my tax refund
which is usually about somewhere around
$4,000 and I put that into a travel fund
and I'd use that money to go
I would book one-nighter gigs and fly to
the one-nighter gigs and then in the
brakes I'd map out and do I call up and
set up guest spots at the a clubs and
sort of use that beast like a Salesman
on the road you know and I you know if I
can go there and wear and do a guest
spot for free and show them my wares you
know hey here's my vacuums you know good
night so it's basically thinking like an
entrepreneur
and think about this is your comedy
enterprise rather than thinking as a
comedian with your you know it gives you
a whole different level of commitment to
it to you're not actually sitting there
with your hat out you're sitting there
with with a as a businessperson
you know saying we have a mutually
beneficial business arrangement
rather than please I need the gig you
know it's just all they look at you
differently when you approach it like
that
and I think it's important comics
understand get funny first like you have
have a have a product to sell mm-hmm
don't try to just jump in if I want to
make five grand it's like we'll have a
show worth five grand yeah yeah the
funny first and then start saying you
have to develop that you have to develop
that act and like you said that the
fundamentals of all comedy is based on
the 1 & 2 liner joke when you can master
that then your stories automatically
become funnier because what does a story
made up of sentences every sentence is a
set up gives you an opportunity to now
treat that like a one-in-two line or
come up with a quick quip or two or
three and then then continue with the
story so if you're writing the story you
can go back through your story and go
sentence by sentence by sentence Sid
Caesar said a joke is a sentence with a
curlicue what is every story it's made
up of sentences so if you go up and take
each sentence and can tag and top each
one with something or maybe not each one
every third one and then now you have a
bit that's humorous overall which you
have jokes on the way to big to the big
joke so that's you know tags and toppers
is the way you get more laughs per
minute you know and it's writing the
story not trying to be funny right write
it as is and then go back through and
start - yeah the intent is to get the
let me tell you about the arc of the
story right so it has the five elements
of story setting theme plot character
conflict and then you have and then so
you're telling the story the who what
where why when and how the moral arc and
all this stuff the moral of story is and
then so you have this great story and
then you but you want to it goes on
forever with no laughs but you can use
technique to drop it in you know one of
the techniques is ask each sentence
three questions one is there a double
entendre
so is there a word that has an implied
meaning I can possibly turn to a comedic
meaning in this sentence just to get a
quick quip you know I came home from
work last night my one you know it's the
night before my wife was scheduled for
c-section so I come home from a gig and
she's laying on the couch watching TV I
said hey babe how you feeling
she says I'm having some gas pains I say
I said well everyone is it's like five
bucks a gallon but and I continue with
the story right it's just a quick quip
on the way to the bigger story and so I
continued to tell the story but every
line gives you something you can play
with then if there isn't a double
entendre play you can say are there two
dissimilar ideas converging here so I
can do an incongruity joke with this so
if there's nothing if that's not
available then you could say is there an
assumption in this setup that I can
shatter I'm teaching my son I'm home I'm
teaching my daughter how to tie her
shoes you know which is weird just 17
and you know you just a quick quick
break this way to the big joke
so it's adding more stuff and that's
just three structures then if you add
cliche reformations you force an analogy
in there that's how Bill burr built its
entire actors through analogy is Mike's
taking two dissimilar ideas and saying
they're similar which sets to the
audience an illogical equation my
girlfriend's like a smartphone huh right
they're asking they're sitting there
with tension now saying solve that how
is that true I'm curious and we'll all
you do is solve for true and the secret
is it's got to be true for us smartphone
all by itself or a per girlfriend all by
itself because if you had it if it if
the verbage that you come up with as the
tie-in doesn't match a person or a
girlfriend then it's not going to work
it sounds forced it's gonna be odd but
if you say my ex like I say my ex it
builds more of an antagonistic situation
I said my ex is like a smartphone at any
given time I can usually find her at at
least one bar
mm-hm and that's what a coincidence
that's so true
but that fits for a person or a
smartphone one bar being the signal of
course right so but that's just by
listing everything smartphone so it's
gonna ask how do you find the connection
between the income group yes so you take
basically take if I decide to use
smartphones say if I want to use
sometimes in this case what I'm doing is
I'm taking an element and comparing it
to my wife
rather than fiying traits about my wife
and then finding the element to relate
it to like if I my ex-wife was a
alcoholic right so I said so I you I
played on that angle I said what else is
alcoholic what else is alcoholic and
it's funny cars funny cars are alcohol
fueled so if I say might want my ex-wife
yeah my ex-wife she's alcohol she's like
a funny car alcohol fueled now I have a
quick joke there but I'm working the
other approach to it the alternate
approach finding what is she like and
then finding something to relate her to
this way I'm taking any element and
comparing it to my ex-wife and then
listing everything I can think about
using subcategories of people places
things words phrases cliches events and
and I'll write that down people places
things words phrases cliches events
every single time I do a list to remind
myself because when you're so close to
it you're going through the list
sometimes you just get too heady and
I'll go on into any cliches here what do
people say when they say this what
people are involved in smart from dude
can you hear me now that guy you know
and I'll just write down everything I
can about a smartphone what else in
smartphone in the minutia the signal
what about the signal the bars hey what
are some of the phrases hey my phone's
only had two bars bar as bar is double
entendre that's a bar could be a
drinking establishment fits from my
ex-wife likes on my ex-wife's like a
smartphone you know at any given time I
can usually find her at least one bar Oh
same phrase fits for phone see wow
that's how that that's and you kidding
bill bar bill bird uses analogy that's
what he uses through his whole thing
once in a while does a cliche drop in
you know so it's a you know like this
thing about this girl he was dating
being aggressive
you know she's aggressive you know she's
like I want you to choke me I don't know
if I'm comfortable with this you know
what if I choke too hard you know what's
what's the pressure what's the PSI you
know
I don't want to choke the horn and she's
like I want you to take me against my
will I was like what is this fifty
Shades of rape you know and he does that
joke of course our brains are wired to
create expectations since we're children
very definite expectations yeah so think
about it we you don't have to rush to a
punch because the audience their brain
is already creating an expectation you
know we don't have to you don't have to
do it it's so firm you go like so if you
say in your head fifty Shades of that
was such a popular book and movie that
people are already creating the ending
so all you have to do switch the last
word and it fits the scenario of him
being uncomfortable because he's like to
force you you know you know it's like
take me against my will what is it fifty
Shades of rape and he gets a quick joke
there because he shattered an
expectation and plus it's familiar and
oh my god so funny how that fits into
this place right here and we didn't even
see it coming
yeah you have you you're going through
like a checklist of all this and you
have like nine
there's like nine elements there were
nine psychological laughter trigger okay
and I'm stimulated that the brain
respond to that triggers laughter okay
surprise embarrassment superiority
release configurational incongruity
recognition and Bivens and and
coincidence did I get all those that's
about nine sometimes I forget right so
then there are 13 major comedy
structures and so the structures pull
the triggers okay so and not every joke
just has one some have multiple once
some have ones where you're like well
that's kind of this and this you know
this is compare and contrast and this
yeah it can be both just like you'll
have literary scholars arguing over
whether something really fulfills the
obligation of meeting complete irony you
know same thing you know if you you
don't have to it's art so and also you
have to remember as Picasso said you got
to know the rules before you can break
the bones
boom it's an art yes so don't get all
wrapped up and it's gotta be this way
you know but a lot of times you can
tweak and go oh if I do make it this way
that joke snaps right and that that's
what part of comedians trying to just
get away with attitude they're not
learning the rules first before they
break right they just see like bill
Burgess up there talking like no he's
worked over half his life at this art
form you know and he says the first five
to seven years of my career I did one in
two liners because I had to know how to
write a joke yeah and that's what I did
too when you know how to write a joke
when you're on on the move when you're
in the flow it's easier to see the
opportunities or recognize the
opportunities and the mechanics and the
structure to be able to spin something
and go oh I just put two ideas together
I'm gonna now list real quick and put it
up there's the here's a line you know
what he does I go he was like everybody
wants to bang a hot chick you know but
you know the the guy working at home
Home Depot can't cuz he's not a
celebrity
besides chicks don't dig lumber right
that's what he says that's his joke and
it's like all he did was take something
from Home Depot every time I see the
name somebody says Home Depot I see a
pallet of two-by-fours and he says
lumber and boom that triggers that image
and it makes us laugh what a coincidence
what were the 1313 if we go into 13 we
have double entendre okay incongruity we
have paired phrases we have simple truth
we have recognition observation so
observation takes the recognition
laughter trigger and you just basically
basically observed the world and
basically explained what it is like
somebody waiting for a bus they stand on
a curb that's seven inches high waiting
for a bus that's 16 feet tall and they
said they're looking for the bus they
don't see the bus so they step off the
curb living losing seven inches then
they raise up 2 inches losing a total of
5 inches to see a bus that's 16 feet
tall if you can't see it from up there
you can't you're not gonna see it from
down there but all you're doing is
taking an observation that's stepping it
out for the audience so that's obvious
and you know comedians should have a
goal of every week write down 5 new
observations in the minutiae of what's
happening in
and so it's just you set yourself goals
so you're always walking around with
comedic glasses then you have then you
have so parrot phrases comedic irony
paradox ambivalence you don't have my
list in front of me and I just got lost
but it's like there's so there's 13 that
you can use simple truth very simple
it's like double entendre but it's a
phrase that has an intended meaning you
find it a lot in songs we speak in
metaphors and euphemisms and all you're
doing as a comedian it's all in having
your cynicism proving it wrong I'm going
to show you that's wrong so somebody
says like a song you go to Disneyland
you hear it's a small world have you
listened to the lyrics it's a world of
joy it's a world of tears it's a world
of hope it's a world of fears isn't this
a song about being bipolar hmm and all
the audience goes oh my god I never
thought about it that way it's so true
because you're taking that simple truth
and you're flipping it scripture has a
lot of symbolism if you take that and
now go to the literary simple truth
meaning you can get a joke its essence
and its foundation goes back to call me
a cab you're a cab mmm-hmm right so call
me a doctor cause they're a doctor and I
you know call me a doctor you're a
doctor it's that same raw form but now
expand it out to other things that we
see all the time you know so that's a oh
you'll notice that Jon Stewart people
say you want to take your comedy to the
next level start to recognize comedic
irony and also a paradox that makes your
brain actually do a dance paradox has
two things that could be true but not
true at the exact same time for example
when Carlin used to say on TV you could
say you pricked your finger but you
can't say you fingered your prick it's
fricking prick two different meanings of
prick they can be true for each of their
meanings and these it but they can't be
true at the exact same time and oh my
god you use them so close together you
know one their same word but so
different so the brain does a little oh
wow that's interesting you know so
that's paradox so there's
lots of so many different ways
ambivalence you can build a bamboo
valent situation and make sure you have
two descriptors in the in the in the in
the sentence is where specifics are
important and comedians sometimes try to
be too economical and they remove a
potential for joke so for example if I
say my dad was just diagnosed with stage
4 colon cancer not a lot of opportunity
there
well foot boy did you know I can add
that attitude maybe you hope for laugh
right but what if I added more of a
descriptor my dad who lives in
Bakersfield was just let's say my dad
who lives in East st. Louis just got
diagnosed with stage 4 colon cancer
horrible right he lives in East st.
Louis so we have we're supposed to be
traumatized over the colon cancer but oh
my god he lives in East st. Louis
you know Esther my son is my son and
Jersey just came out of the closet oh oh
that's what you have a son who lives in
Jersey right so it's like using
ambivalence quotient it's supposed to be
upset about this but instead I must set
on the set about that so that extra
descriptor helps you get there you know
that's another technique you can use
yeah and is there other resources like
this for this on your website as well
yes lots of them so and on the youtube
channel here's what's well here's
something really cool hahaha
masters series you're familiar with the
master series master class yes great
right
Ron Howard does one Steve Martin he does
comedy blow me away
Steve Martin was my favorite guy when I
was in high school sit was Jerry
Seinfeld right so and I you know of
course I disagree with Seinfeld when he
tells people you can't teach people out
of do comedy but he still he was my
favorite he's still one of my favorites
but I disagree with you Jerry I'm
writing an article it's gonna be called
the big lie Jerry Seinfeld wants
everybody to believe I mean there's
there's techniques people can use just
like I think learning an instrument but
not everyone's Jimi Hendrix right people
can learn the basics of it but to what
degree does you come down to some
national village if they practice and
practice and practice and practice this
has been proven now there
but called peak written by K Anders
Ericsson and Robert Poole and their
psychologist and they've been studying
for the last 30 years the psychology of
mastery huh and what they did was was
they studied like violinists what
separated the best from the best of the
best the best of the best practice more
and had more expert feedback so that's
what real practices is practiced with
expert feedback so when you take say
Jerry Seinfeld wrote five hours a day
always was at the club's bilborough's
always at the club's doing his thing
he's always there he's always working at
least one to three shows a night right
so and the Willman went from two years I
met her at coached her a little bit and
she got on Stephen Colbert last year's
been on she she's awesome yeah
and she she was also coached by Gabe
Abelson who wrote for Letterman she was
looking to get better and better and she
got in Colbert but when I met her she
sent me a video of her I go you're so
good why are you coming to me and she
said I want to get tweaked it so I can
get on a late show and I said I can help
you with that and then she said I said
how did you get so good how long you
been doing it she said two years Wow how
did you get so good fourteen mics a week
yep plus at X being open to notes being
open and seeking out expert feedback
yeah so that's the key so K Anders
Ericsson says anybody can master
anything they want he firmly believes
that because the brain is highly
adaptable and so it's like wow now I've
seen people I've taken people who are
absolutely unfunny and now their friends
call them funny so it's very interesting
this guy Braun Olga Lucia Croatian right
he goes my dad my father used to say
don't laugh it makes you look stupid so
I was never funny so now I have nephews
and they're funny and I want to be able
to keep up with it can you help me he
was showed in my class regularly who was
an adult school teacher right and
there's like and he started doing mics
around town eventually and people saying
you're a really good writer you're
really funny then he was on campus
it is school and he was with other
teachers and he saw a poster on a kiosk
he goes now that's really funny I think
what's so funny about that
it said domestic violence workshop
Wednesday February 14th mmm that's
hysterical
why is that funny give your wife a
Valentine's gift don't punch don't punch
her in the face you know because this
incongruity right and so I was like see
now he gets it you know he can drive
down the street and go look all thick
Chinese cuisine se habla espanol you
know he now sees he's identifying this
because now he's open to it right right
now he's not Jerry Seinfeld but he's
he's certainly a whole different person
yes he's now got a sense of humor that
he didn't have before because he didn't
recognize what triggered laughter and
how to apply it but you you got to do
the work who a man without a doubt and
he did three years he came to every
class okay yours plus English was a
second language so we had another
barrier yeah but he said I'm going to
learn this and he just kept applying
himself asking questions to the homework
all that stuff so the master class Steve
Martin said was interviewed one time and
I followed Steve forever and he was
interviewed one time are you gonna get
back to stand up I said good that's the
question I've been asking and he said no
it's too hard
then why I found who's teaching this
masterclass on comedy go well what's he
gonna teach if it's too hard
mm-hmm so I got the master class I'm
watching him basically talk about did
you watch it you know watching him talk
about being you know just his life and
comedy and everything and he goes and
you want to learn how to write go to
this website and look at the 13 comedy
structures and it's my [ __ ] website
yeah I was blown away students started
to call me oh my god Judge Steve
Martin's master class says you ever has
your website on it they're using you go
to your comedy structures what blew my
mind do you mean even now humbling is
that you didn't even know no nobody
getting paint just started getting
pinged yeah dude that was really kind of
a humbling experience but had almost
lots of years to my honor Martin Mike my
idol yeah Steve's like my favorite too
it almost like I almost like teared up
at that moment so like crazy my teared
up when I heard about it I can we got my
favorite comedian the world you know I
was like you did you know that's so
awesome I wanted to tell everybody it's
incredible yeah so that's that was
really cool dude so and all of it was
just is just focusing on trying to give
people the best tools
yes that's it if you stay focused on the
intent whatever rewards come to you I
mean that reward I can't put a dollar
amount on that like my idol comedic Lee
just referred them to me when it comes
to writing a joke oh my god right how
amazing is that
and so that and and but every time
somebody says anything to me that the
compliments I get on on YouTube somebody
put on there you're the goat you know
and I had to look up what goat man right
why you could make me a goat I didn't
know what that was and so um and anytime
somebody gives me any kind of compliment
like that that just reminds me I have to
work harder mmm because now you got a
bar to uphold right yeah and it's like
thank you that's nice but that just
means I have to work harder and keep
keep working and keep helping and you
know run into somebody experience a
problem how can I help them solve it and
that just helps me get better too
yeah I think in 10 super important
because with with me not taking the
comedy school route I the red flag was
my intention is to literally just like
make money I was like I'm literally only
doing this because it's been my primary
source of income for the past few years
so as soon as I let go of that those
almost constraints like I got I think
I'm gonna make this work cuz I got to
make money because I did my parents were
teachers and I do enjoy helping people
but releasing the class helped me to
realize oh but this podcast is helping
people when I'm at shows and absolutely
questions that's I'll still helping
people but the intent is to now do this
to help as opposed to well I got I got
to do this class but then I gotta do
this workshop to to supplement Inc like
you know right as soon as I release
realize my intent was not in the right
place then that's when the career just
started to I mean you always have to
keep the lights on you know it's
but it's it's if that if the money is
your objective if Fame is your objective
that's so fleeting you know and not
sustainable he's not he wouldn't be as
successful as you are if you were to
cycle let me just horde all the comedy
secrets and make yeah well not doesn't
do anything it's gonna help everybody I
mean people get better there's more
funny people out there now you know cuz
I don't know if you know this but most
people don't that when you laugh your
brain releases the same exact feel-good
chemistry we release when we fall in
love that's powerful yeah it's also the
same chemistry if you shoot heroin but
it's true it's the same exact hormones
are released when you laugh so manually
or spontaneously so you can chemically
change your mood if you're in a bad mood
just by making yourself laugh for one to
two minutes I mean chemically I mean
that's like taking a drug and it's
better than than a drug so because it's
more sustainable but what I found in
I've just started to put a more personal
spin on my comedy in terms of like I've
been working hard you become an [ __ ]
of a dancer well yeah though they'll
hear the seminar the podcast seminar I
did here at world series where I got
heckled and called an [ __ ] and all
that and the word that came from sorry
I'm so glad you were there dad I called
him dad sarcastically but incredible and
yeah so but what I found is when I
become more personal people I've started
to come up to me like telling me
specific jokes as opposed to like oh you
were funny and they can't remember
anything as soon as I started make it
personal and have an emotional
connection they were able to come and be
like oh that's just like my wife or my
dog she treats our dog like that or my
grandpa said the same thing to me and
you mentioned in the the Greg Dean's
story that you were you helped that
comedian inject emotion into it because
for a lot of the years my comedy was
more surface and it works because the
math adds up I think Greg Dean was
trying to help him and check that
emotion
yeah yeah he was laying into a block so
I kind of distracted him and showed him
he couldn't label it so I said what
about one of these words here and that
snapped his brain out of this sort of
intensity and he would say well oh these
two right here okay let's see if you can
make that happen yeah that's what I was
trying to steer you into is so weird
saying comedians need to learn the
structure first but then how do they
start to inject that personal touch that
you brought that up the best piece of
advice I got comedic ly as a stand-up
was from an acting coach hmm and I
studied in Lee Strasberg theatre
Institute in LA and some of the some of
the intense you know acting schools
my dad was an actor studio guy and so I
was studying with a teacher named laelia
Goldoni
she was unbelievable because she never
let me get away with my [ __ ] tricks
you know because those were my defense
mechanism trying to hide the fact that I
feel vulnerable and put up this defense
mechanism like I'm you know oh you know
my humor I'm in control and teaching me
that I am perfect in all my flaws so
show your flaws no no problem with that
because people now connect to you she is
secondly when I did five minutes for her
in front of the class the jokes
mechanically were sound I know they were
good jokes they laughed
I got laugh so I was like ha showed her
she sat there with her arms folded her
legs crossed and she said oh look Jerry
thinks his jokes are so funny he doesn't
need to perform them and I said what do
you mean by that
and she said I don't know how you feel
about any of that so I don't care humans
connect through emotion Jerry go back
home I want you to write down how you
feel about and play the emotion make
sure it's authentic through each of
these lines connected to the environment
connected to the pictures in fact don't
even think of the emotion think about
the colors and the textures and the
sounds and the smells of the events
you're talking about automatically the
emotions will come to you and so I
practiced what she said by at the same
time rolling my eyes
mmm-hmm I'll show her right I go back
and I said I'm just say my dad always
said anytime a acting teacher gives you
a note don't ever take offense to it
they're not saying it because they
dislike you they're saying because they
want to help you and that gave me a
whole different perspective so somebody
gives me a note I never say oh [ __ ] you
I'm like what do you mean by that always
follow up with a question or two it'll
help you to clarify what they mean so I
came back and delivered it the way she
said and holy [ __ ] what a difference
applause breaks on jokes that I just
thought were funny what else in people
oh my god and what you said exactly
happened to me my brother does the same
thing or my father you know it's like
the same thing and I was like now well
you're affecting people you're not just
making them laugh yes they were leaving
with an impact how did you how did you
inject that emotion you said you'd think
about the smells and sense well sir
that's one of the lessons in acting
instead of just trying to play sad
that's so general sad what do you mean
sad distraught you know upset
what good but if you remember the smells
textures and the scene about where that
emotion is connecting to that's when the
emotion comes out okay so you're not
just playing the label of an emotion
you're playing an experience so it
changes the way you play the experience
it's like when when I coach actors
sometimes on self tapes and a lot of
times they deliver the lines looking at
the character all the time watch real
actors they'll look at the character
maybe 20% of the time especially if
they're talking about an event the event
we go somewhere in our eyes to the event
in our memory and then we check in with
them once in a while so if you're really
remembering an event or substituting a
real event in your life for that
character you're gonna that emotions
gonna come to you hmm
and as comedians we get good at this
because we do it every night expressing
herself over a certain
subject or emotion or something if we
can play sarcasm we can play we can play
retaliation benign retaliation is
another structure very important
structure probably a great structure to
open with okay because I call it the
perfect joke form because it's got an
antagonist and a protagonist built in so
you can say that like when people say
hey you're comedian tell me a joke I
always tell them a joke because if I
just say I don't do jokes they do
stories what are the odds of them coming
to any of my shows zero but if I give
them a joke
that was funny where are you playing
here there's an app on my phone I opened
it up it's a form they put in their
email they had send with their first
name they had send it goes they
automatically get an email response that
leads them to a two or three minute
video here's a clip you know enjoy I'll
send them something else I just use I
use MailChimp MailChimp oh yeah I create
a link on I have it on my Evernote I
just hit that and it opens up the
website with that form on it and they
put it in and I say I'll invite you to a
show it it's my fan list yeah I think
this happens all the time
oh you're comedian well tell me a joke
and I'll tell him a joke the joke is
usually my ex who cheated on me called
me on Halloween she's like Jerry I don't
know what to pretend to be for Halloween
I said why don't you just just normally
and pretend you're in a committed
relationship
that's funny were you playing right and
it's that simple you know and it's
rather than oh no dude rupes or do
stories the reason we most of us say
that's because we're not prepared yeah
to say a joke why not you know how many
people have come to see me based on that
you know probably hundreds you know
based on meeting people and asking to be
on that list you know by saying hey tell
me a joke you know so I just rambled no
you didn't know that was all relevant
hmm so with that was there anything else
with injecting emotion you go to the
place or you bring in a parallel
experience to find the emotion within a
story don't chase the emotion I'll sort
of let it come to you clearly just say
you know oh my god
let me tell you about this my my ex
she's like just she's a plus plus you
know that's the that's the positive way
I tell my kids you know she's [ __ ]
nuts it's what she doesn't but she's all
I'm doing is I'm picture
during her picturing those situations
how did she make me feel sometimes she
gets me so [ __ ] frustrated and I just
not afraid to share that with the
audience that does take practice and
that comes with learning to be yourself
the way you are with your friends at a
bar on that stage because we tend to I
want to put on my best self on this
stage rather than I want to be
completely vulnerable and be the same
guy I am at the bar on the stage and
that's why I tell the audience I'm but
like I'm so flawed you know I got
baggage I got Samsonite you know but I'm
not afraid because that's made me who I
am mm-hmm and being able to be that way
and be honest with them on the stage now
you're communicating with them you know
like it though we're watching the World
Series of comedy a lot of comics good
jokes but I don't feel the connection
I don't feel them connecting with the
audience at all you know there's they
want to get up there and recite their
jokes because they have a time limit
yeah you know and it's like be with us
doesn't matter the amount of lab point
you get if you're with us there's
nothing on there that says how many
jokes did you do per minute on the on
the judging application or the form
it's like originality stage presence
overall performance those are the three
criteria but yeah laughs per minute do
matter but are you really still
connecting with us and communicating
with us but I've been doing this nine
and a half years and I'm just now
starting to kind of open up that level
of comedy and stuff just now like
peeling back that layer of like oh the
personal and what's finding the
emotional connection behind it so it's
like I've been on stage a lot and I'm
just now getting around to oh yeah
motion is important and you know I
should tell my story and tell jokes that
only I could say and I try to put my
jokes through a filter now of like what
can I do that someone couldn't steal
really mm-hmm
you know I try and I'm trying to put my
material through that filter but I mean
it's not given up on them no way you're
gonna stall in a lot lots of time since
so it's like Jay Leno give me a great
piece of news after he stole your dude
yeah exactly right oh they also got sued
lots of times for a lot of jokes being
stolen because the head writer was not a
great joke writer great ad-lib guy but
he was a not a great joke writer well
the late night show
like Twitter they've been accused of
stealing tweets and stuff as well they
did that with Conan yeah what what gets
me is Conan it first stuck to his guns
he said nope I'm gonna fight this and
then they finally settled with this guy
and if the judge only knew how you write
jokes she would have seen how easy it
was for him to come up for them to come
up with this parallel thought on a
current event and I wrote one of the
jokes he was yelling about the night had
happened it was like when when the
Seahawks they they threw that pass play
on that that third down a fourth down
play at the with two minutes two seconds
left on the clock or whatever it was
they threw a pass play when they had the
best running back in the league and it
was like right on the goal line and they
got intercepted because of course
Belichick knows that Pete Carroll is
gonna think he's gonna run so he's gonna
receive he said his defense for pass
snap that ball away and they want now I
said wow the MVP award goes to Pete
Carroll right right there at the just in
my house and that was one of the jokes
this guy argued that was his original
joke you know and I didn't even tweet it
because I thought it was so low hanging
fruit because it's just right there and
so they'd Conan did a version of it and
this guy did a version of it and it's
like but if you list it's right there
you know so if if the judge knew how
jokes were written the judge would have
said now there can be parallel thought
so but there's a lot of people that
complain about that I have I wrote some
jokes you know when Trump said I'd go in
there even if I wasn't armed about the
Parkland shooting I said yeah you cuz
you could you could you could hurt a
[ __ ] with a bone spur that night
Stephen Colbert did to bone spur jokes
and I tweeted that I don't think he took
it from me
right it's right there you know so I let
him go like Leno said just write more
yes yeah
and writing is a muscle and it requires
a lot of reps and the I feel like just
for people listening like the techniques
and tools we're talking about require
time and repetition and writing is a
muscle and the more you do it the
stronger it gets but it is it's gonna be
incremental
and I'm part of developing the comedy
muscle and we can we can land the plane
with this question cuz this is something
I ask every guest is like the an epic
bombing story like getting booed on
stage or I mean getting up your bottle
thrown at you if that's the one that
comes to mind for you but like in your
over 25 year career like do you have a
show that just sticks out is just like
just that gig you'll never forget let me
see I think that one was see I don't
really see that beer bottle as a bomb it
was going well up till then and I did
get punched in the face - after that -
because but I I don't want to tell the
story because these days with this
political correctness people will see it
as racist because it was it was in a
town it was there was a table of cholos
and they were having a good time but
there was a misinterpretation between
playfulness between the guys sort of
ribbing each other as guys do and then
the sum of their ladies thought it was
too personal and they got personal with
me and called my mother a [ __ ]
and so I had said a response based on
factual information yes and the way I
said it was inappropriate and they had
no place to go so that's when the beer
bottle was thrown and I deserved it
but someone's breaking in yeah that that
full story is on another podcast no
matter which one but I came across that
story in researching you know someone
wants to hear it they can hear in its
entirety on if you just search Jerry
Corley on the podcasts you know we're in
the breakfast area uh yeah that's right
now you have it you have a different
show that comes to mind yeah one of the
times when I used to I heard from
Seinfeld too that he liked to he'd like
to do he'd like to open for bands more
than they'd like to work with comedians
so
and I just heard that and so I go that's
so I had friends and as a played
trombone and a horn band myself so I
knew some musicians I had friends that
had this fusion band jazz fusion band
that was doing a lot of spots around LA
so they would always call me and ask me
if I wanted to come into a spot and I
would do like their breaks and so one
time I did a break for them at this
place called the rusty Pelican in
Calabasas and so I'm doing I do a break
for them and it wasn't going well
mm-hm and I could tell I heard these
what these three guys were standing off
to the side I hear one guy one guy say
oh look he's bombing let's [ __ ] with him
so they sort of walked towards the front
of the stage and one person would yell
something and as he ran out of breath
the other person took over and it just
was not there was no way that I was
going to overcome this and this is what
happened I I said well it looks like you
guys are creating your own show so which
it probably explains why you're single
I'm gonna leave good night got some
laughs from a couple of people over here
who are now rooting for the poor failing
comic on stage got off stage went to the
bar and said [ __ ] it
I'm gonna get drunk and so I the
bartender delivered a beer and as I'm
delivering the beer I take my tape
recorder and I set it on the bar and
it's still rolling and I go holy [ __ ]
this is the black box of an airplane it
has all the data that led up to that
crash I said I'm gonna take this home
and take every line these [ __ ]
said and write a comeback to it Wow and
I turned it off and I said that to the
recorder and I went home and I wrote a
comeback to every single line those guys
said Wow and that's what and then I said
that's never gonna happen to me again
and so that's what I did so it was like
that was empowering yeah to realize that
wait a second I've got the data right
here I can I can write a line to come
back to everything they said what went
wrong do you think I had a couple of
jokes new jokes that failed mmm and so
they saw that as a weakness and this
audience is not a comedy audience this
audience doesn't is like they're there
you can talk while the music is playing
so but and all sudden I'm more of an
imposition to them this time so most of
the time it worked out well and it
really got a chance to work those chops
but this time they just didn't want to
hear from me and these guys noticed it
and decided to take advantage of it
because they want to feel better about
themselves so that's what happened
that's one of my favorite lines oh look
he's bombing let's [ __ ] with never
forget that beautiful just that
epitomizes just a comedian on stage
failing and just the sharks in the
audience that's so oh it's so funny but
the other thing we have to understand
too is the audience psychology right
Bobby Slayton in a documentary called
it's called it's alone up there
interesting ok it's done by a Canadian
filmmaker and I'm I'm in it he
interviewed me and I I watched the thing
Bobby Slaton's there Bobby Slayton says
it's an us against them mentality and
I'm like that's so far from the truth
because we've sat in those seats and
we've watched comedian after comedian
get up on the stage what is our
disposition in general it's curiosity
who's next what are they got so it's
never nuts against them mentality just
knowing that stepping on the stage
changes your entire psychology of what
this audience is looking for they want
to laugh they're curious yeah so why
would you say it's an us against them
thing maybe that's part of his persona
cuz he was the Bulldog of calm yeah so
you got to stay that Bulldog guy but
it's got to be a different age for him
now this PC environment oh my god no I
hear Seinfeld getting upset about it all
these guys gonna well write new jokes
adjust you know you can't tell society
what to do you can sort of press against
it a little bit make your complaint but
they're gonna they're gonna have that
they're gonna default to what they
that's a that's a generational thing now
you're dealing with it's not a it's not
something you can change overnight you
know you can mess around with them a
little bit but they're it's like doing
Trump jokes the moment you do a Trump
joke you gotta tensing up attention that
room up you know
so it's like somebody's gonna want to
fight you eventually so that's what
happens that's throw beer bottles I had
again I had a guy want to fight me at
the Comedy Store doing a Trump joke
brilliant three and he said wanted to
fight me so he got up approached the
stage oh that must been more recently
yeah that was recently oh so you're
still out in the yours young man I love
getting out right in a Comedy Store like
I'll go to the improv oh oh did the
Icehouse hole I do corporates I still
whatever I can I go out and do something
okay good cuz it's like I'd love it I
still got to connect with people right
sharpen the sword - that's exactly right
you know there are times and like I got
to be doing more I got it and I'm doing
it at least twice a week but it's like
you know doing like Comedy Store The
Improv but to be able to go out for a
week is different you know do be able to
do a cruise but then you know I can't be
gone because they're still having it now
I have an eight-year-old at home and my
wife is an airline pilot mm-hmm so she's
gone I'm home you know so it's uh that's
good we got to work that out yeah but
that is the mindset of a comedian as you
see me even like Joe Rogan
multi-multi-millionaire still on stage
multiple times a week you know sign
soaps still on tour like as a comedian I
mean you're the stage is really that's
the laboratory we could write we can
ride all day you got to take it to the
stage yeah the audience is always the
final judge yes even though you think
you have 98% odds the joke is gonna work
there's still that 2% you may lay
something out in flatline yeah and then
you'll ask him why didn't you laugh at
that and they and they usually tell you
you know and I've had comedians on here
say their success rate is like 1 out of
20 but I feel and the comedian's
listening go to your website go to
Jerry's website and look at the reet
like well Steve Martin says do it right
you might as well go do it we're gonna
we'll link it in the show notes to this
episode as well just you can jump to it
but it's gonna help you like the success
of your jokes it's gonna help you write
more jokes better and faster I would
imagine yeah yeah and you own begin to
the key is I think understanding why why
it works
mm-hmm once you understand why it works
it like oh [ __ ] yeah okay I got it you
know and you're white a John Doerr House
author of the comic
tool box said the rule of nine when you
write ten jokes nine are gonna suck get
over it but I think once you understand
I've seen in my classes every tonight we
do current events jokes seven out of ten
work Wow are really effective jokes and
I'm I try to be very objective about it
and go okay is that a good joke or just
I'm just a big fan of their them
overcoming an obstacle and so that's a
solid joke and then also the class will
laugh right so seven out of ten they
usually get that nail it some nights six
out of ten but it's rarely one out of
ten they're usually on point more than
they are not so but Jen they've got to
still maintain that discipline and
regimented practice yes every day man
every every day just like a musician so
you kids know out there watching and
listening
you have your marching orders you do the
work all right do the work you're gonna
want to listen to this with multiple
times because there was a lot this is
this may be the longest one we've ever
done we had fun though yeah it was yeah
it was exciting cuz I mean I've been a
fan of you and it's cool to see people
sharing all this comedy information but
with the right intent you know right so
before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
or any closing advice you have for
comedians I think you said it do that
it's all in doing the work if you really
love this and want to have a level of a
success you got to make that commitment
to do the work every day every day like
every day you're gonna Jean parrot said
I write every single day except for the
weekends because I made my wife that
promise but he set a schedule and I
guess that's the important thing is in
your date book and your schedule on your
phone set as scheduled I show up for
work at this time and if you don't do
that you won't because I find no one I'm
gonna wait till I'm inspired that could
be weeks yeah to get that right signal
of inspiration rather than just sitting
down creating inspiration you know as I
doing [ __ ] you can sit down my wife is
like a smartphone my wife is like a bank
and then list bank you're gonna find
something in their release or that
relates to that now my wife is like
about us she always wanted me make 24
hour to park pause
so it's like she's like an ATM at a bank
now you just tweak it and it's like just
finding a second element in practicing
with it and you'll find something in
there that fits most of the comedian's
won't do the work they won't like 2%
this is the last thing I'll share
Sunshine's law it's a philosophy
professor gave to my dad and he passed
to me 2% of the population excels at
their specialty 18% or average or just
above and complacent staying there the
rest of the 80% are in a declining scale
of incompetence do you want to be
acceptable or do you want to be
exceptional
Jerry Corley everyone thank you so much
my pleasure for me that the timing of
this was so perfect as well
so please let let the listeners know how
they can keep up with you support you
like my listeners not my listeners the
hot breath averse is what we call this
like they reach out to guests they'll
reach they'll reach out they'll be
reaching out with questions I just had
Craig shoemaker was on here he's great
comic in San Francisco who loves the
show reached out to him ended up driving
to LA to meet with Craig like the the
hot breath of ours is very engaged and
these are people who love comedy and
you've really done such a great job of
creating a community too I mean just
listen to your seminar I'm gonna I got a
tune in because you had breatharians or
breath of hers like reference and yes
it's like that's awesome such a good
tool to use to create the community in
fact I was I went back to the room and I
toyed with the idea of what to apply to
my sort of community my tribe yeah and
I'm thinking as an angle how can we all
how can I help you all become joke
doctors yeah so just based on what you
had said and I saw that was so meant
that moved me I said well I want to be a
part of this community you know because
it was so neat that's why church is so
effective because it you know I'm not a
religious person but I love the idea of
the community you know people getting
together so kudos to you for that and
thank you and yeah
man I'm very active on twitter twitter
is I hate Facebook because it takes too
much of my time although I'm starting a
group now based on what you said oh yeah
because I do have a Facebook group
that's called Corley's kids it's only
four people have been in my classes but
I want to open something up some more to
people that are on like YouTube and I
think Facebook's the better vehicle for
a group certainly than Twitter yeah
people contact him contact me on Twitter
at at Java and I recite Rai to respond
to everybody people ask me for advice
some help sometimes I'll fix a joke if I
have the time I'll help somebody but I'm
always active there because it's quick
you're in you're out
you can do it on the fly right Facebook
I always get distracted with other stuff
and now next thing you know it's 90
minutes of my time on the window but
definitely going to do that group but
Twitter it's a great way to reach out to
me okay yeah and your website is
stand-up comedy clinic ok cool calm
perfect alright well Jerry Corley I feel
like our communities have a lot of
parallels and over that a doubt you know
I'm hoping this is not the the first of
many times we can go this is gonna be
this is gonna be synergistic I can tell
when you were up there I go oh we're
gonna have a good relationship this
because he's got a good philosophy that
helping people and it's like this will
be fun yeah I was a little nervous with
you and I was excited you since you
stayed cuz I just watched yours a few
hours earlier I was like oh man he does
is professionally I was a little nervous
that you were sitting there and like I
don't know if you were listening or just
like well let's just see what this kid
his kids all about I want you going
watch it going well he's an [ __ ]
no no it was like I still don't know why
he said that man I will every I've never
what was neat about him saying that no
you're being an [ __ ] I'm serious
you're being an [ __ ]
and because I've never seen a roomful of
Cobb comics beep be Bill wildered at the
same time
what's he doing serious he's just being
comic you know in some comics we were
like trying to speak up and I was trying
to be it's okay it's okay I'm up here I
can control this but it I'll put the
link to that episode in the show notes
cuz I was recording the whole thing yeah
and you can listen to it and hear for
yourself yep great
all right Jerry Corley thanks about hot
breath my man my pleasure a lot of fun
that was a fire hey hot brethren and
sistren thanks a lot for watching this
video if you love comedy as much as we
do here at hot breath click the
subscribe button to join the hot breath
averse and then watch more videos to get
even more comedy tips and stop sucking
at comedy go ahead click it